[Music]
the penny farthing was the first machine
to be called a bicycle
[Music]
they're old they're funny and for some
still a big deal uh sometimes i go into
a local bike shop just for a bit of a
joke and ask me if i've got a tire to
fit my bike and then bring them outside
have a look at it
[Music]
people find the funny farving almost
hypnotic i don't know why i can't
explain it but people just love seeing
it and it's just a real pleasure to
share it with people richard being an
already avid bike racer discovered penny
farthing racing on an internet forum one
night
so i entered immediately uh very excited
and then realized that a i don't have a
penny farthing and b i don't know how to
ride a penny farthing but he overcame
those hurdles
i'm the current uk champion so i've got
title to defend
but penny farthing raising isn't as easy
as it looks and it sure doesn't look
easy it's a very dangerous machine to
ride you're sat up on top on the point
of balance virtually so if anything goes
wrong you tend to be going headfirst
over the front of the bike the bikes can
be up to five feet tall and that height
has its benefits racing one of these
bikes uh pretty high up you get a
fantastic view of the crowd it's the
best way to see the event here i always
tell people height is not the only
benefit the penny farthing has big
difference between riding a funny
farthing and a normal bike uh is uh you
can't slow down very quickly you've got
to watch the road ahead but i find the
biggest difference is the smiles on
people's faces when you ride one of
these things people just love to see it
they smile they wave they pull up take
photographs
i've so many conversations with people i
would never ever meet without this bike
and that's the joy that people just love
seeing it talking about it
[Music]
i think liz is crazy but in a very good
way i think he's very smart i think he
knows what he's doing people think he's
a sadist or whatever he's like my trail
soul mate flair for the dramatic i think
a bit of a sassy man
laz cantrell
a true backwoods rebel of tennessee
created one of the world's most grueling
foot races one that is so challenging it
leads many to assume it must be an act
of sadism
are you a sadist
no no i think people are obsessed with
comfort to the point that they forget
if you don't have any discomfort in your
life
how do you know when you feel good
the barkley marathons is a 100 mile race
comprised of five 20-mile loops that you
have 60 hours to complete
it's over some pretty rugged terrain
it's got a massive amount of climb about
66 000 feet
you have just your map encompassed it's
cold it's wet it's miserable you're
alone
the fact that they'll probably almost
certainly fail makes it more appealing
it started in 85 and uh we've had 14
finishers
are you all about ready
you start the race with a cigarette
light which feels very untraditional for
most race starts yeah we always use a
camel because that's about the best
cigarette i think
[Music]
the course is located in frozen head
state park
home to the brushy mountain state
penitentiary
a location not chosen by chance
in 1977 james earl ray the man who
killed martin luther king jr made
headlines again when he escaped the
prison
in the 54 hours he was free he only made
it eight miles from his cell
because this terrain is no joke
don donald said man you could put
together a race course that would really
challenge people's soul
i think every runner would like to do
better than james earl ray and get
further than eight miles although some
of them don't
everybody gets a bib number for each
loop
there's paperback books which are kind
of strategically placed so that to get
them all you have to follow the course
and you pull out the page number that
matches your bits
you have to turn your your pages to show
that you've done the course
he has a brilliant sense of humor he's
parodying the sport of ultra marathon
running
those of us who run ultras we have a
certain
egoism that we think we're pretty good
because of what we can do
and so he set out to puncture that
balloon
laz keeps making it harder
because he's trying to put it at the
limit of human possibility
[Music]
after they've decided that they've had
enough and quit we play taps on the
bugle both because taps is what you play
for someone who's died in action
and because they they're being tapped
out
i think genuinely in his heart he wants
to see people succeed
when people actually finish five loops
and you see him at the end he's so
excited
[Applause]
when and if one or more of them comes in
it's an inspiring thing
it's hard to believe a human can
accomplish that
it's good that some years no one
finishes because the barclays should win
sometimes too
[Music]
when you roll up to that line you are
getting butterflies in your stomach
you're nervous you're sweating but once
you get the bug you get hooked and then
it's all over
[Music]
we're celebrating our 23rd year of the
top cop program here at sonoma raceway
top the cops is a program where high
school students can come out to the
racetrack on a wednesday night
race their car
against a uniformed policeman in a stock
police car
i'm kevin mckinney the program director
for the top the cops program i'm a
retired law enforcement officer from the
santa rosa police department we've been
doing this from april through august for
the past 23 seasons
there was illegal street racing being
done in and around the city of santa
rosa
and i thought
we need to get these people over here to
the racetrack so they stop doing that
out on the street
if you want to race
fine come on out here and race don't do
it out on the street
[Music]
these are our future these kids here
i pull up next to a cop at the start
line i always just think oh great if i
beat them it's a great feeling when you
pass them on the drag ship going 100
miles an hour
there is a very competitive spirit to it
but you know it's all about the kids
there's a lot of negativity in the world
today a lot of negativity towards law
enforcement
what we try to do out here
is make something good something
positive out of this program something
that is worthwhile
nowhere in the country is this being
done on a regular basis the top the cops
program did help curb illegal street
racing it's been a great positive
program all these years
[Music]
you got to be
a certain type of person to get into
flying without an engine
the fact that we're able to leave the
ground leave everything behind
fly through the skies on nylon and
strains is exceptional
the rat race is a seven day long
paragliding competition with 200
participants that also serves as the u.s
national paragliding championship
[Music]
my name is nick griese i'm a
professional paraglider pilot
a paraglider race is very similar to a
sailboat race
they race around buoys we raise around
several different gps coordinates that
we have to hit along the way
each morning the race course is
determined by the weather for that day
and a course typically ranges from 40 to
70 miles long
the first person to finish the course
every day gets a thousand points if
someone's five seconds back they get
9.95 and so on and so forth
and then at seven days you add up all
your scores together and whoever has the
most points wins
[Music]
i grew up in long island in a suburb
close to new york city
i went to beloit college in wisconsin
and after that i returned to manhattan
to take a job at a pr firm
my second day of work was september 11
2001 so i was walking to work i saw the
first plane hit the world trade center
from the street
i don't know if that played a a
significant role but it played some role
in me deciding that i needed to do
something
sooner than later if i wasn't completely
satisfied with what i was doing
so i sold all my possessions i lived out
of my car
all i did was fly
i've dedicated my life since 2001 to
flying paragliders for many years i've
been one of the top pilots in the u.s
and that to me is a sign of success
watching the start of a paragliding race
is a sight to bold
a hundred pilots launching off a hill
and then getting up into the starting
paddock which is what we call a gaggle
the start it can be a chaotic experience
of people that are trying to get to the
top so that they're in the best position
so everybody jockeying for position
once that starts it's just a glorious
experience of you know rallying through
mountain ranges for a whole day with
your friends
after seven days you're pretty exhausted
but you know that's also the the real
joy in doing any kind of endurance event
just like with anything whether you're
trading stocks or
riding bikes or flying paragliders
you're always trying to make progress
and increase your ability to succeed
and you know paraglide competition is a
beautiful example of pitting your skills
not only against your competitors but
against the elements
[Music]
the most unique part of rally car racing
is if a regular person were to hear the
in-car audio of a driver and a co-driver
it would seem like they were speaking
gibberish
in actuality it's a language that tells
that driver what is coming next
they really are just the eyes for the
driver before they can get to that spot
[Music]
rally car racing in america is stage
racing
you can have anywhere from 12 to 14
stages
anywhere from six to
20 miles in some cases i mean you're
racing other competitors but really it's
you against the clock
so inside of a rally car we have two
people we have a driver and a co-driver
the driver drives the car
tries to keep it on the road without
wrecking it
and the co-driver
is responsible for reading the notes
50 turn a left three will tighten right
three minus no
cut so for this example we have 50 here
so that means before the next note i
call you'll have 50 meters
and then t for me stands for turn which
means you'll change roads from the road
that you're currently on and then a left
three left obviously means your corner
is going to go to the left and a three
is the degree of the corner
there's so much information to take in
from the co-driver you say 120 miles
over a weekend there could be as many as
two to three thousand
different commands that co-driver is
reading the driver
pretty much that co-driver you know is
the computer of that car he or she is
going to get you from point a to point b
and as a driver you need to trust what
that co-driver is telling you
we started
as a team when i was 15
and um sometimes i feel like i can
simply read his mind
i really trust what she is telling me uh
to the point where if i had to close my
eyes and maybe not drive at race speed
she could tell me pace notes
and i could still drive blind into left
three
into right four up
king seventy
right four long up tightens at t to a
right two break turn left three off
camber
into a care left three down fifty
turn left three tightens to the right
three minus
rallies let me see how
you know one of my children has grown up
and how they've become if i looked at
her as a co-driver and not a not a
daughter or a relative i'd i'd grab her
in a heartbeat
i'd love to make it a full-time career
one day and and rally internationally
and i'd love to just follow in my dad's
footsteps
[Music]
you